aujourd'hui le sentiment il et il a un
peu compliqué c'est à dire par rapport à
tout ce qui s'est passé en six ans là
honnêtement on est une sorte de colère
mais après on est on va dire dans les
perdu un peu parce que on a on n'a pas
de retour concret il ya un an j'avais je
m'exprime est exactement de la même
façon il ya un an j'ai dit on est dans
la tente
hélas au bout d'un an là depuis
que l' enquête de l'igpn s'est terminée
en mars on est encore dans la tente et
je trouve que c'est l'attenté vraiment
trop longue c'est à se demander
c'est à se demander s'il n'y a pas
quelque chose qui se cache derrière tout
ça et voilà c'est beaucoup de sentiments
mélangés par rapport à par rapport à
tout ce qui a pu se passer avant et tout
ce qu'on a pu ressentir dans toutes les
démarches qu'on a faites vous en six ans
vous avez vraiment mener vous avez mis
la pression aussi sur l'étape qu' il ya
des enquêtes qui soient faites
est-ce que vous avez quand même
l'impression que les choses vont avancer
ou vous a l'impression qu'on s'est
arrêté au milieu du gué quoi en six ans
il s'est passé énormément de choses
c'est à dire que nous on a frappé fort
déjà au bout d'un an
même avant ça a été très prématuré dans
la sphère on a eu très vite une
convocation auprès du ministre de la
justice qui ont reconnu un
dysfonctionnement très très graves des
services de protection
ensuite on a eu
[Musique]
beaucoup de changements politiques un
président comme ministre intérieur
donc il ya eu des échanges de courriers
il ya eu des réactions nous avons fait
des émissions diverses des radios pour
se faire entendre et pour qu'il y ait
une réaction réels par rapport aux
négligences de deux policiers de
gendarmes concernant d'autres affaires
ont bien évidemment on a eu une réaction
de gérard collomb qui a diligenté
diligenter une enquête approfondie sur
sur ces dysfonctionnements tout
simplement
et cette enquête elle a duré deux ans de
l'igpn
qui s'est terminée en mars donc deux ans
c'est déjà long vous imaginez que c'est
pas ces bas et du coup aujourd'hui c'est
quoi vous vous dites il ya cette enquête
mais en fait vous la connaissez on ne
sait pas on sait toujours pas ce qui
c'est ce qui s'est passé quoi l' enquête
l enquête elle a duré deux ans il s'est
terminée au mois de mars et on n'a aucun
retour c'est silence radio
moi je trouve que vous savez il ça
commence à jouer avec lui mais là on
joue pas on joue avec l'humain on joue
avec ont joué avec la suivront n'assouf
avec notre souffrance on joue avec ma
soeur c'est là haut et on joue avec
toutes les autres femmes qui sont
victimes de violences conjugales
parce que notre affaire elle n'est pas
qu'elle est peut-être transparente en ce
moment et à d'autres affaires
actuellement qui sont qui sont va dire
en tête d'affiche donc je parle pas que
pour nous aussi après pour être un petit
peu plus personnel c'est sûr que là pour
une autre affaire pour aurélia on a
envie d'avoir les résultats l'igpn
complet
des résultats à notre attente c'est à
dire que les personnes qui ont négligé
dans la sphère sont négligés soient
sanctionnés moi je demande qu'ils soient
retirés de leurs fonctions ces personnes
là
je vais vous dire une chose et ça je
rigole pas
si début septembre on n'a pas un rapport
complet je fais la grève de la faim je
compte apa
6 ici il faut frapper fort on va frapper
fort moi j'ai contact avec des
associations association sociale fatigue
elle fatigue parce qu'elle se bat vient
avant ma soeur qu'elle se batte et je
comprends maintenant tout ce qu elle
tout ce qui s'est passé avant et
maintenant exprimer encore se passer
après et franchement ça fait peur on est
dans un milieu on est quand on est
plongé dans des dans un système
judiciaire comme dans un combat comme le
nôtre comme d'autres aussi
eh ben
on se rend compte qu'il faut batailler
bataille et bataillé tout en tout temps
pour se faire entendre
aujourd'hui vous dites bon il ya cette
enquête qui a été fait qui a été fini en
mars
vous avez l'impression qu'on vous qu'on
vous cache la vérité qu'on veut pas vous
dire vraiment qu'il ya des gens qui sont
protégés enfin c'est quoi votre
sentiment par rapport à ça moi je vais
vous dire une chose
il ya eu des associations qui ont rendez
vous au ministre de l'intérieur et quand
ils ont évoqué l'affairé aurélie a parlé
il ya un sentiment de malaise
voilà donc ce que ta maman
maintenant ça me surprend pas parce que
le malaise c'est vrai qu'ils ont un
depuis quand même quelques années autour
de tout ça et c'est quand même passé des
choses étranges et eu quand même des
alliances des amitiés policiers
meurtriers des plaintes pas entendu
maintenant je pense effectivement qui
cache quelque chose c'est quelque chose
qui peut pas être dévoilés ou qu'on a
peur de dire à travers de nous dire à
nous aussi
et puis à travers les médias je pense
il ya donc le ministère de la justice
madame tenir à vous avez enfin avait
présenté les excuses en disant
qu'effectivement il y avait une faute de
l'état vous vous attendez aussi la même
chose de la part du ministère de
l'intérieur c'est ça aussi aux qui
manque aujourd'hui les premières étapes
de notre affaire ce ministre de la
justice 1 on a été reçus d'ailleurs avec
grande surprise notre avocat aux six
mètres en 2 h 29 heure avait été très
surpris de cette convocation
on a été reçus par des représentants qui
nous ont exprimé vraiment leurs excuses
en disant que effectivement il y avait
un dit son dysfonctionnement
dysfonctionnements graves dans la sphère
de ma soeur voilà donc à partir de ce
moment là c'est une reconnaissance et
tout ce qui touche après la police
gendarmerie
voilà c'est à tous plus le ministère de
la jce
ça touche le mr à l'intérieur donc là au
bout de deux ans on repart dans une
autre bataille et cette bataille là où
seule bataille là nous avec moi je
n'attend même pas les excuses ministre
de l'intérieur moi ce que j'attends du
ministère de l'intérieur
c'est des sanctions et un rapport
complet pour comprendre comment le
meurtrier pendant tant d'années a été
complètement protégé parce que c'est
s'annonce et de la protection donc et
puis et puis ensuite savoir pourquoi
parce qu'il ya une chose importante que
je veux dire c'est qu'il devait y avoir
une perquisition d'armes à feu au
domicile du meurtrier
elle n'a jamais été exécutée elle a été
demandée elle n'a jamais été exécutée ci
aurait eu cette perquisition
ma soeur elle sera à côté de moi sur ce
banc voyez et ça c'est ça en fait oui en
fait oui on revient sur un sentiment de
colère parce que parce qu'on a plus quoi
après on va pleurer
on n'a pas assez pleuré moi j'en ai
marre de pleurer
par contre y en a d'autres qui
pleureront un jour parce que vous savez
pendant ce temps là qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est que pendant toutes ces
années il ya des gens qui dorment
tranquilles dans leur lit pendant que
des familles elle souffre et quand je
parle des autres et ceux qui font pas
bien leur travail et vie qui ont
provoqué la mort de ma soeur parce qu'il
ya eu le meurtrier ni à tous cas
autoroute la négligence devait faire la
négligence des services de police et de
gendarmerie ont eu un
un rôle acteurs dans le meurtre de ma
soeur et ça j'en suis absolument
persuadé on n'enlèvera pas un dernier
mot sur le fait que vous l'avez dit
aujourd'hui on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
il ya on parle beaucoup de des
féminicides puisqu'on en est déjà à 90
voilà ce matin j'ai encore eu une femme
qui a été tuée par son conjoint soit 1,8
ben là on est apparemment déjà 90 100 90
déjà les humains tous les jours il ya là
vous vous dites quoi parce que à
l'époque on en parlait beaucoup moins
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que la
sphère au relais vers l'est elle a servi
elle a peut-être permis de libérer la
parole mais en même temps ça va pas
régler le problème
ma soeur d'appât et alors concernant les
féminicides ma soeur ça a été une
affaire médiatique qui a été comme la
sphère vela dans les années 90 déjà déjà
la porter plainte contre l'état c'est
c'est une mission super difficile
notamment dans dans la ténacité quoi
parce qu'il faut franchement avoir les
nerfs solides pour s'attaquer à l'état
féminicide
il y en a toujours eu autant même avant
que moi je me lance dans ce combat il ya
eu des féminicides sauf que maintenant
bien il ya tout ce qui est médiatique
autour et les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'il faut bien savoir que les
réseaux sociaux ça a commencé vraiment
au facebook 2011 tout ça donc on parle
beaucoup plus des féminicides à travers
les réseaux sociaux
il ya beaucoup plus de communication qui
se fait à travers sa moisson en
communication avec des associations sur
des réseaux sociaux
tous les jours je vois une femme deux
femmes tués
baptisé puis des armes aussi des hommes
tous les treize jours dans les
statistiques un homme effectué par sa
mort il ya eu un élément peut-être
certainement déclencheur dans le combat
dans la ténacité du combat et ne pas
avoir peur de s'attaquer à l'état parce
que c'est des gens humains comme nous tu
peux faire des heures qui peut faire des
people il peut y avoir des erreurs mais
il suffit juste de le dire et de le guen
va te faire attendre
comment on peut faire attendre des
familles comme ça